[Musique]
voyage en absurdie que je fais lorsque
je m'ennuie
j'ai ma gêne et sans complexe gars matin
je changer le sexe que je vivais des
trans
[Musique]
mais une femme
femme des années 80 mais femme jusqu'au
bout des seins ayant réussi la marianne
de l'autorité et du charme fin des
années 80 points que l'on vit qu'un
requin sachant vient de plus haut à
gages qui va de grands sourires on m
avait déjé au manoir sexy comme
autrefois lescar est brun général
on trees où les pasteurs aux conscrits
enfin de jusqu'au fond des yeux qu'on a
envie d'appeler monsieur aime l'afrique
ou pompiers services et donner le sein
elle
femmes cinéastes et qui vinrent à la
fois poète des mannequins femmes
panthères sujets à peau lisse et femmes
bancaire clan pied en suisse fans des
bruins dominaient pham directeur de
cabinet à la fois sensuelle et pudique
et femme chirurgien esthétique une
maîtresse mais sa vie n'est d'entre eux
mêmes très sale usines vers le matin les
abattoirs elle dans la soirée le toit
fermé gardiens de la paix chauffeurs de
cars agents secrets femmes général
d'aviation où les dégâts mais le peloton
ray major de promotion par le silence
ceinture marron championne du monde des
culturistes aimé ici après la licence
art jusqu'au fond des yeux quand on a
envie d'appeler monsieur en robe du soir
à talons plats qu'on voudrait bien plaît
pas ma femme pilote de long courriers
mais femme à la cour contre les galonnés
jusqu'aux grands caractères ou stewart
rouler des pelles maîtrisé à fond le
système accéder au pouvoir suprême
s'installer à la présidence et de la
faire porter la
mais
femme est gardienne de frison chanteuse
encaissent des francs-maçons une série
je vous attends permis aux emmerdes
on n'en fait plus femme conducteurs
d'autobus fort trianon deux opus on a
envie d'un peu les gens qui met quand
même bien sans soutien gorge
femme des années 80 mais fin jusqu'au
bout des seins
fin des années 80 points colombie
sachant bien venir sur la garde
grand sourire aux larmes
il
[Applaudissements]
un pdg
sexy comme on nous voit rizla général
d'aventis
qui considère
quarto était mannequin
[Musique]
bancaire conquet monfils ferme des baux
le cabinet à la croissance anémique
[Musique]
sion par les rssi ramsar
plus qu'un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]